what do you have to deal with physically
now a lot really I know you I know you I
broke your back
you broke your back I remember your
Taliban birthday present yeah sure of
injuries I had like my rift in my hands
oh I'll be sitting there in my hand
we'll just start akin I don't have like
holding on to something and my thumb has
so many issues my thumb will stop
working and I got these twitches and I
just dropped whatever half so I have
something fragile have something and
you'll see me drop stuff and I'm just
like I just couldn't hold it it just my
hand didn't work so that's both my hands
are arthritis snakes I have a lot there
in my elbow blew that elbow that's why
it sticks way out I hit here so hard it
broke my all Knights the radius and ulna
I shoved up through my elbow and so it
sticks out still through the elbow I
wouldn't do that
pushed it up through it was a really big
fall that happened in a country we shall
not name but it was like it was a it was
a herd I just taped it was riggers tape
and put it back in place
mmm and then I had like another one
where tore my shoulder out did that my
knees and a dad broke that ankle
somewhere else I broken every finger in
my hand this rib eye fell through a roof
in a in another country and it hit air
and it broke on my ribs I climbed back
up to the roof as I feet with dangling
third reefs I'm going ahead so that's
another funny story
it was a it was a it was funny but uh my
body armor Burke and that one one would
have cracked my body armor Burke Burke
some ribs and stuff and they you were
falling off of a ship at that when you
bounce back right it was a shipwreck he
didn't break it like I like to crack it
wasn't like that about ever breakers it
was it was a it was um a fracture that's
a little fracture it was it was a
partial fractures a bunch of partial
fractures and cracked everything out but
didn't in a Burke one of the de
cushioning the what do you call them
yeah have blast yes so I have black
discs and have gray discs and I white
the white ones that a healthy was a
fluid is so good the gray ones that a
fluid is kind of disrupted it started
getting older if the if the disk is
black and x-ray you can see it if the
disk is black that means basically Auto
flute in there that gives it cushioning
has all turned solid kind of so it's
just us it's just it's like more bone
between bone so I basically made a
couple bad discs and I fresh hit watch
the bones so I'm still able to operate I
can still move around but is this really
painful so because I was laying on the
bottom of the boat i watch the guys were
kicking me as they're going past get on
a ladder
they're like pick it up let's go man
kick me on the way out and so I'm laying
there getting kicked getting kicked and
I'm like damn alright and so I got up
and I jump to the ladder and I was like
dude stop kicking me I'm gonna get up so
I got up I was like ah I don't hurts I
don't know what I heard someone thought
if I climb the ladder with like 40 or 50
pounds
I had a rucksack on with it you know
songs and stuff all my ammunition and
guns so basically it's like doing 30
pull-ups with 40 pound 50 pounds on your
back with a broken bones so you're not
able to use your feet when you're doing
that yeah use your feet your hands okay
okay but basically using your feet your
hands with all the weight on and getting
up the ladder
okay cooker but it's a lot of arms to
climb fast use a lot of arms cuz because
we use our feet you're not as fast so
basically you're skipping up with just
doing pull-ups
so you're just skipping up really fast
and you only hook and basically just a
little bit of your heel on the ladder
sui heel is barely catching then you're
still pull-ups and your heels are going
to so it's real quick you heat up a
ladder fast if you do it right wow it's
been amazing hearing your story and and
the perspectives that you're able to
give from your experiences what is the
message that you want to communicate to
people whether it be young people who
maybe want to join the military or
anyone in the world what what do you
want your legacy to say about you
and how do you want to help other people
I mean that's it's a huge question I
mean everybody everybody has a legacy
but most people's legacies are forgotten
one or two generations after they pass
away so what what's what's anyone's like
it's gonna be is it can be written down
is it just like this little podcast
that's in video this is forever
this podcast it's in Fitz and zero so
it's ones and zeroes bits and bytes so
this podcast is forever
there's documentary film lady valor
which is about part of my life is
forever as part of my legacy part of my
legacy is mindful valor foundation the
nonprofit that I started that's part of
my legacy I mean that's what you have to
consider is that it's just like going up
the ladder so every rung of that ladder
is part of your legacy but is it the
same or is it building and you learn so
every time I make a mistake I say hey I
own it this is what I want to do better
and that's a rung up is the stabs of
[ __ ]
I wrote a book on a book of stabs so if
you think about a rowboat every part of
that rowboat those little the runners
along there's a staff and more stabs you
have to hire up the gunnels to hire up
the sides of those boat Co so you can
handle more and more harsh weather so
more staff you have the higher up the
boat go so you can handle bigger and
bigger seas staff is also the runt of a
ladder so if you're a kid you're in
grade school you're building up a staff
to play good with others that's what
you're first to have it's play well then
you get another staff your ladder gets
more and more rungs more and more staffs
so why did this thing called The Book of
staffs and staff number one is this to
have - is this staff three and each one
of these are lessons that I've learned
in life and it goes up to like stab 200
or all these little things that I've
learned all these lessons that I've
picked out and these staffs put together
make a pretty sturdy little boat that I
can handle the harshness of the world's
oceans I can handle the harshness of the
intellectual ocean of the spiritual
ocean
of that like the tough ocean so if all
you're doing is building staffs of
toughness doing pull-ups and push-ups
wake up early in the morning well your
boat is pretty weakened to other waters
you know might be strong in the Erie
Lake Erie but when you try to go to the
Pacific you're not gonna be very strong
because he never did a mental stabs you
only did one set of stabs so your staffs
that you have and you build up your
strength should be a combination of
mental staffs of toughness staffs of
weightlifting staffs of nutritional
staffs of spiritual staffs of you know
camaraderie stands of colleague staffs
your staff should be so assorted and so
diverse do you can survive in oceans in
any ocean in a lake in a pond on a
stream on a river you can't just make a
staff that survives the oceans what are
you can do any go in a river
so the Buca staffs there's a combination
of lessons it's combination of of pearls
of wisdom that I've learned over the
years the hard way through stories and
things that I know because I learned it
so I'm gonna give you a little story
this is how it happened this is what I
learned so book of stabs is one of those
kinds of books so that's why we talked a
lot about toughness and I talked about
the SEAL team training you can get
through Steel SEAL team training if
you're pretty mentally tough and you
have a lot of physical strength with
some luck you can get through but
there's other things you probably
couldn't handle is you have no I take
intellectual or spiritual or you have no
compassionate staffs mmm to walk past
something to see you know what a person
really needs a hand the catheter that
ship he had no compassion he saw
somebody in and needed it that person
was in a hole and having a really tough
time and that captain did nothing more
but dig that hole deeper and sucked that
person deeper in a hole and that person
committed suicide I would say that
captain's one of the weakest people I've
ever met my life
his shift would never survive in the
waters that I've navigated he calls
somebody to kill themselves
now when you think about your life and
what your leg is is gonna be a UFC
fighter who freakin was super tough and
a ring and I can I won't name him but
you probably know other person he's very
notorious he's a tough guy man he's
notorious and that guy is probably the
biggest a hole in the world he has zero
compassion he was ooh an intellectual he
has zero spiritual her very little of
all the above but the guy's a winner in
UFC ring but a loser with everything
else
his legacy is one fold his legacy is so
a single dimension it's pretty weak
I want my legacy to be across all that
doesn t v-- super deep in one or
anything else but I wanted to be pretty
bra I wanted somebody to listen to me
I'm gonna go to him into that show
spirit old pretty strong made it through
buds also think about stuff I also admit
to make mistakes also tries to be better
and all that stuff Wow okay I get it